next we got home kill your name buddy
but matter who sh nani acara
clearly from cleveland oh I like that
hair bro Mayo me some of that hair
god damn you saw Minaj Bosh from Dubai
and trunking I got you a club for you
guys great here I go with the boys or
hang out with your girl but with the
girl sex off the table you know what I'm
saying not even them pretty buzz little
hitters boy Gang Gang
buzz buzz and feel if he comes here boy
diamond give the win from that hump
Jitsu guy Nobu Janabi hit me up I would
love to see you I sure enough said
humped you - he's actually pretty good
buzz buzz oh I love this guy this guy's
awesome most mana Boosh cool-looking
booth dude this guy here's the thing
what a great question here's the thing
my girl knows this like we're best
friends but we're not best friends
I have best friends you're just the
closest female friend I have really if
Dolph for sure dude I'm gonna get some
[ __ ] for this oh yeah I'm gonna let you
hang yourself dude they call the Rope
maker hey no sex so we're just chillin
I'm gonna you know my boys man I mean my
boys are get a place live together you
know I'm saying no brother
we're sewing it as fast as we can
dude camera you're telling me if you're
besides Derek come on but in general
your girlfriend it's obviously a kidnap
victim okay
the whole thing's just cuts and leads
away from the bus and that's at home oh
yeah the 50s Derek litter flapper wings
get outside the [ __ ] apartment open
the window every now and then at least
let her change
Derek who I see buying wd-40 for all the
chains that he's got on his girl all the
time
this poor girl they first of all I love
you I'm look at a bush and I hope to see
you soon if I was coming to Dubai
brought we would definitely kick it man
I really appreciate this foreign shout
out and uh and yeah hump Jitsu this is a
[ __ ] good that's kind of a nice name
I I didn't I couldn't pick up what he's
talking about khabib style fighting
Jitsu interesting when he gets on and I
think it's probably got to be hard to
wrestle somebody who also if it's a
tough man feeling like they're humping
you a little bit it makes it a little it
makes easier for you to win a thing but
no I mean look Kobe was amazing
obviously cheering for Dustin Poirier
and uh and he's amazing to barroso
anything can happen that's the thing
they got a fight they did it there only
one way to find out baby Saturday and
get the get the pay-per-view by I think
it's gonna be a good one man 11:00 a.m.
we're doing a fight companion for it so
help views - yeah oh wow it's crazy man
I'll just be at my place I guess but um
anyway so what I'm saying is this dude
I'm gonna verse is that I called him his
name you Frances name
Boosh did you call well he just called
him you see the spelling it's a family
dude just pick someone who maybe you be
a sh Y am I gonna bash nice yeah might
get a bus might get a but I'm not gonna
wish first of all I'm not gonna bus you
seem like a nice gentleman and I'm glad
you are doing well and um and yeah if
friend hanging out with friends or just
a girl what was it hanging out friends
or your girl but you can't have sex
there's no sex so you'd rather hang out
with a girl or your boy where your girl
well are we watching Dateline what you
watch whatever you want do you and your
friends watch Dateline know it would be
uncomfortable watching my friends yeah I
got a watch just with my girl yeah I can
watch it I can't watch 90-day fiance
with Pheo you know
good bro would you get together watch a
90 day fiancé breakdown yeah people
would love that
oh yeah I think we're the only ones that
watch it but let's do it we are not only
to watch a dude
billions of people watch it my favorites
the black guy who has the hottest
Russian girl but she just never texts
them back I just he's made plans for two
years and keeps sent her money and then
he'll be like she sent this video four
months ago and she like what's up babe
babe I love you and he's at the airport
he's like I still haven't heard from her
but my bags are packed and we're meeting
in Mexico of course you'd show up
first of all also it's about time we get
some of these black guys back for the
Nigerian scams that have been going on -
you ain't lying but I will say this that
I think if you're watching a certain
Show Dateline 90 day fiancé that's okay
Ghost Hunters yeah Real Housewives
Orange County if you're watching a real
piece of [ __ ] television then definitely
you want to do that with your old lady
yeah because you're not gonna judge you
yeah my boys a clown before watching
[ __ ] the match already so it's only
good early on when it's chaos yeah it's
the [ __ ] out of uh when they got people
in their name like lavender yeah and
like yeah they have like and they they
have to pass certain amount of black
people and you know the the girls not
into black people it's so strange to me
man oh when they do it like that want
they just yeah but I think someone's you
don't know if it especially these days
but I think I just don't know did you
see when it was the black girls the
Bachelorette and so as a bunch of black
dudes that she's picking them though and
they're playing basketball and that's
they're playing like a pickup game to
win a date with her and homeboys married
and his wife he comes in the gym you've
never seen that one oh dude she's like
you're married
he's like dang am i bad girl from The
Bachelorette if I could real loving
hip-hop real quick
ABC's like anyway so girl or guys boy
like I said depends what you're doing
right yeah and I think
yeah yom-yom area that you would love to
see when I get over there at Abu Dhabi
in the future further for the winner
when could be once his reap when he
wants to try to get his belt back I'll
come over there they ain't doing it
there again yeah please don't just get
the belt back they're doing new it's
just doing an American do it anywho here
that's a [ __ ] place that people can
get to dude I win on the globe to look
to see where it was so first I go to
London I'm like okay I've been on that
plate before I can kind of see what
that's like then if you spin the globe
19 times the other direction
finally with Abu Dhabi pops up you spin
it 17 times nope you're not getting in
it's almost like one of those locks on
your locker in high school it's like
it's just right dude you just stand out
there just yeah what do you guys think
let's go really let's get our jet let's
get well we know what charities say well
I don't have a girl right now so Oh
ladies in the front ladies in the mad
dead bodies in the front bodies in the
back cheese in the car her chin in the
back yeah yeah I'll have my voice to you
so you'd rather hang with the boys no
girl
let me ask you this though chick it's
hypothetical - guys not really I mean
real this is the animation from Aladdin
hey nobody if you were gonna go eat
Korean barbeque what you do all the time
would you rather be a table full of your
girlfriends or your boys well remember I
told you that if you go with Korean
girls they kind of do everything for you
Oh
girlfriends but yeah you do get to sit
there and just kind of mass sleep even
they cook you get sleepy if you want
they cook they porridge shots
it's like Derek's girl Wow that's
Derek's lifestyle bro yeah yeah Derek's
girl or we or the missing person it's a
girl or the [ __ ] living space
the sex slave he keeps no like it's
worse for that girl yeah see Derek's
girl on these wanted posters before cat
chilling with you late you seem like the
type there's a lot of guy friends uh
yeah I have girlfriends too I think as
much as I like hanging out with my man I
gotta hang out with my girls yeah that's
my girls cuz when you're with your
significant other they want to have you
make like the most responsible decisions
that's here's the other thing there's
not much to talk about
there's not much to talk about I been
with my girlfriend a hot minute dude
sometimes we go to jail like a lukewarm
in it now soon as you go to dinner just
stare at each other
it's a staring contest she's winning
yeah no I think that I think what you're
saying is really true cat that yeah it's
like would you say again I just want to
go and have if I'm trying to have fun I
want to go out with my girls yes I'm
trying to have like a low-key night then
I'll go with my man right it's
interesting yeah it's like you can't be
irresponsible as you said it can't be
irresponsible around like your
significant other especially because my
group of friends are enablers so that's
usually how they get wild cat damn damn
girl I have fun Oh even can turned a
little bit of gin [ __ ] put his Qi
Shuai yeah Jim got the cheese you'd say
go on you like a sharp cheddar
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching